you may be limited in what resources you
have but you should be unlimited in your
resourcefulness as an entrepreneur I got
a question from dennis is one of our
readers who says i'm in bosnia and it's
hard to start a business there's poverty
everywhere it's hard to get a diploma
what should I do I'm answer for you
dennis is as long as you tell yourself
that you can't be a successful
entrepreneur because you're in Bosnia
then you won't be we're all fighting
their own bottles everybody's fighting
their own war now i cant pretend to know
what it's like being in Bosnia I've
never been I've never tried to start a
business there so I can't say I'm in
your shoes but I do know that as long as
you tell yourself a story of why you
can't succeed and you believe that story
then you're never going to succeed we
all have obstacles that you have to
overcome but the fact that has never
been easier to become an entrepreneur in
this digital age it's never been easier
to achieve success there's so many
examples all around us that should
inspire and motivate to give you ideas
to succeed I remember doing a
presentation in Brunei is in Asia and
for them it was a group of young
entrepreneurs and for them it takes six
months to set up a business to get
through all the red tape and bureaucracy
to start a business and open up a bank
account six months and it was shocked
I'm here in Toronto Canada and I could
set up a business within a day I have my
license I have my bank account I'm good
to go imagine having to wait six months
just to get anything off the ground
would you do it and there are a lot of
guys there are a lot of young
entrepreneurs who said you know what
that's too much work because I'm in
Brunei I'm never going to make it I wish
I could be in America or in Canada and
you know what those guys aren't going to
make it there's another group who said
you know what it's hard
take me longer than my other work in
other places but I'm going to do it
anyway these guys were young and they
were ambitious and they were hungry and
you can see that they were going to make
it no matter what obstacle you threw in
their way they were going to overcome it
and that's the attitude that you need to
take as an entrepreneur because it's
hard it's hard for everybody you need to
have the passion and the desire to
succeed to bust through all the brick
walls are going to be placed in front of
you whatever limiting personal believes
you have and whatever story you keep
telling yourself that's what's going to
hold you back from achieving your
success whether you think you can or you
think you can't you're right so I hope
you'll apply that to your business and
believe that you can still be a huge
success you could change the world you
can achieve greatness despite coming
from Bosnia or wherever you are or
whatever personal limiting beliefs you
have good luck so those are you watching
please give the video a thumbs up if you
liked it and I'd love to hear what kind
of questions you have about your
business if you want to leave it in a
section in the comment section below so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
you